le spectacle avait coulé série il est
17h45 alors je vous dis ça me charrie
beaucoup avec l'équipe alors déjà je dis
voilà je suis très très heureux tous
retrouvés aujourd'hui elle fait son
grand retour valérie bénaïm hélas brabo
gilles verdez sofica rené malleville moi
personnellement moi je vous dis moi je
suis inquiet déjà pour les personnes qui
travaillent avec cette eau là je veux
bien les croire c'est vrai qu'il existe
deux réseaux différents tant que tu l'as
dit l'eau non potable qui est pris à
paris et l'eau potable des parisiens qui
arrive en amont du sud de paris par le
baron haussmann qui a fait les travaux
c'est un jeu c'est l'eau est à sens et
haussmann est belle grande qu'on fait ça
à l'époque en 1850 pas cela fait dix
mois et s et stéphane bern ou c'est
raymond là vous allez voir à la fin
pilot challenge et je peux vous dire que
sophie cost c'est quelque chose ça mais
d'abord cage pour expliquer aux gens et
une en garde que ça fait une heure et
demie que vous m'avez dit bat naître un
oreiller pour marc rich and brain shake
mon oreiller ma ceinture dans mon salon
donc je le tente pas une ratatouille
pour demain un gars super en quête de
vos bas niveau depuis le challenge et je
me fais bien quand même un bel vas-y
balles ainsi qu tu peux rester comme ça
ma chérie tu préférais ni comme patron
laurent wauquiez ou moi dit la vérité
alors là la fed a vu comme c'est marca
les questions questions
j'ai posé une question à chacun une
question qu'il faut dans la merde
l'aggraver mais oui évidemment à siéger
dans ce monde c'est évident mais ce qui
étonne mais vous êtes super top c'est
fou ces hommes politiques qui savent
jamais répondre à une question dit la
vérité et je veux que tu répondes
franchement si tu devais de toute
l'équipe
tu dois sauver le monde du coucher avec
un mec ça peut être mature tu te tutoie
ligne dit la vérité ait maintenant prête
moi ta main dessus alors voilà et ben
voilà
maintenant il va falloir que mature
veille mathieu tu voudrais pas que tu
vis marc hématologie déjà mathieu donc
obligée de tout dire sophie davant quoi
mathieu vous a proposé quelque chose
il m'a proposé il m'a dit qu'il était
estate et qu' il voit là ils pouvaient
très bien fonctionné à voile et à vapeur
ça ne dérangerait pas alors il a fait ça
mais tout le monde veut matthieu
delormeau donc tu as décidé de maîtriser
l'année prochaine
j'ai eu une vie pendant dix ans dans la
finance pendant dix ans dans la
télévision c'est de la finance m'ennuyer
celle de la télévision m'a passionné
mais c'est vrai que j'ai souvent fait
les choses un peu par obligation et à la
base dans mes rêves vous avez toujours
voulu quand j'ai commencé à faire du
droit être commissaire de police ou
travailler dans la police
j'ai toujours voulu faire ça et c'est
vrai que on en prend très peu 1000 à
1200 parents il fallait faire une
maîtrise de droit
bon il faut que la vie s'est pas fait
comme ça et l'autre jour j'allais au
téléphone mon ami m'a recueillie et
fogiel et je lui ai dit j'y pense de
plus en plus c'est quelque chose qui me
passionne aujourd'hui je cours plus
après l'argent ou la célébrité je crois
pas quelque chose qui me donnera
l'impression de me réaliser
bonjour monsieur prenez ce national
oui je viens de vous je suis derrière
vous depuis un petit moment vous avez
les conduites dangereuses
vous êtes derrière on fait donc vous
êtes derrière moi depuis longtemps mais
j'ai rien senti monsieur c'est bien que
vous ayez l'humour monsieur dans 2
minutes vous n'aurez plus donnez moi vos
papiers vous étiez plus de 50 km heure
au dessus vous allez donc avoir un
véhicule qui va être saisi également le
permis monsieur vous mettez des enfants
en danger
vous aidez souple et déjà dans un ballon
pour voir si vous n'avez pas bu d'alcool
car vous avez une salle s'est pas créée
par bill c'est j'ai pas bu d'alcool
c'est juste votre terre qui me revient
pas oh la la
alors là ce qui se passe on pourrait pas
le voir je te dirai monsieur sorti du
véhicule tout de suite
sortez de quoi à sortait du véhicule de
votre grotte 4 4 noir est riche sortez
de votre véhicule
alors je n'ai pas quatre taxes noir par
contre tu vas voir un gros 4 4 dans la
gueule à calar que la crèche de 10 la
semaine je te prends une clé de bras
je te pauillac sur le quercy sont
honteuses d'accord blagues sur le capot
d'accord je mets une première menottes
je mets la deuxième voilà pour être sûr
de maîtriser l'individu surtout lorsque
la personne comme toi et à fonctionner
c'est quoi votre blague vous prenez vous
connaissez la ville à la vitesse limite
quand on fait l'amour dit mas et 68 km
parce qu'à part fait état que allez
sortez le mois des confiner la nuit des
conteurs est ce qu'on peut faire une
petite barque à je te fais la musique de
la musique des ringards tintin dont
c'est la question qu la question où il
ya quelque chose dans braquo dans l'ue
d'ailleurs est ce que tu peux pas nous
faire imaginons voilà qui est ta femme
dans le lit tu arrives tu rentres tu
rentres dans le champ et tu nous fais un
petit strip si oui mais d'abord le
métier comme à bordeaux
[Musique]
aujourd'hui pascal adam et eve étaient
noirs comme ça aujourd'hui hanouna un
ouvrier au smig obtenu un médecin du
coup il prescrit du doliprane
ce remboursement est le même ça c'est un
scandale aujourd'hui il peut se passer
de dix balles par l'ouvrier donc arrêté
de me dire dont les gays et gaullistes
on ne parlait pas laissez-moi lui parler
s'il vous plaît c'est un forcené je vais
m'en occuper mais il a peaufiné je vais
m'occuper de la justice au pas on n'en
rajoutez pas laisser parler le
fonctionner après on donnera par le
forcené en notre âme et conscience
excusez-moi série tomber les arrêtent
leur âme et conscience
[Rires]
le chanteur dazhou qui a cette fois ci
cédé à la tendance dans un live
instagram pour la bonne cause le célèbre
interprète de rain a décidé lui aussi de
mettre à profit sa notoriété et son
carnet d'adressés pour récolter des dons
au profit de la fondation des hôpitaux
de paris et l'unicef en particulier pour
soutenir les pays d'afrique qui
connaissent un moment particulièrement
compliqué de leur histoire une
ribambelle de stars parmi lesquelles
kalach kenji vita antoine griezmann paul
pogba inès règles ou encore cyril
hanouna cyril qui a décidé de rejoindre
le live pour soutenir son ami appeler
aux dons mais aussi contribuer à
l'effort je voulais t'appeler ce soir
ouais ok mais que tu es toujours là pour
toi comme tu es toujours là pour moi
et 33000 là à 22 heures foot en direct
j'aimerais qu'on passe directe à 58 un
don qui a fait exploser de joie d'être
jouée au total en quatre heures de live
l'artiste a réussi à récolter 200 mille
euros de dons bravo à dudelange mais
peut-être qu'il y aura un début des
conflits sont ses plus sachez qu'à
partir du 11 mai 1
on sera pas donc voilà en configuration
taille touche pas à mon poste
on va faire une émission avant voilà une
émission voilà d'humeur avec des images
bien sûr des rigolades des et on aura
chaque soir on va essayer de mettre en
place trois ou quatre chroniqueurs avec
moi bien sûr à distance 1 et on va
essayer de faire ça ça va être de 19
heures à 20 heures et à 20 heures
on vous proposera un jeu quand je vous
dis un jeu a priori on va là c est ça
peut changer à tout moment je me dis
vous proposera un jeu mais quand je vous
dis un jeu ça va être un gros jeu pour
la rentrée donc épais de retour bien
entendu à la rentrée forcément
sachez que tpm paix va encore repartir
pour je vous dis au moins deux à trois
saisons nom de daniel russo voilà avec
moi j'espère si vous voulez toujours de
moi les chroniqueurs bien entendu voilà
donc on va repartir pour deux à trois
saisons de tp ce qui veut dire qu'on
arriverait peut-être en treizième saison
qui serait une honte voilà